it's the holiday Rush
millions of Indonesians living in cities
are traveling to their hometowns to
celebrate either fitted with relatives
it's a nine hour train journey for Corey
fahrina and her family
I want to go to my hometown because my
parents are there so I'll make the
effort to go back I feel sorry for them
they miss us and we haven't been back
for a while
this year authorities are expecting
around 120 million people to make the
journey known as mudic that's 40 million
more than last year
19 travel restrictions imposed earlier
meant many people haven't been able to
travel in years
I'm so happy that I'm going to go home I
couldn't sleep last night I couldn't
wait till morning I'm excited that I'll
see my family soon I haven't been back
in a year
but it's presented authorities with a
challenge in an attempt to reduce the
numbers of vehicles on the road free
buses have been made available
each bus can carry 55 people this will
reduce the volume of vehicles on toll
roads and other roads and make it easier
for people buses are also a solution for
those with motorbikes because motorbikes
are not designed for long distance
travel and are often involved in
accidents so we are asking people not to
use motorbikes
other measures include making some
highways one way to ease congestion
authorities hope everything runs
smoothly for what could be the busiest
Smoothie King yes I said Big Al Jazeera